the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we in a manner of speaking
start the second part of this part of
our course that what we have done up to
now is hopefully to have presented the
concept of partial derivatives in with
all the trimmings and now what we would
like to do is devote the remainder of
the course to what we could call
selected topics in which the partial
derivative plays a fundamental
underlying thread in in other words a
situation in which we will now pick
specific areas of calculus and show how
what we've learned about partial
derivatives can be applied to these
particular areas
now the first natural area which would
suggest itself it seems to me would be
the concept of integrating a function of
several variables since after we study
derivatives we next associated the
definite integral with an anti anti
derivative it might seem that a very
natural inquiry now is to discuss the
concept of infinite multiple sums as
being the analogue of the definite
integral in our study of calculus of a
single variable now because these topics
that we're picking have great
application and have been studied in
great depth we by necessity will sort of
skim the surface of many of these topics
so that we can present as many of the
key points as we can in the time
allotted for the course we will make the
lectures hopefully as short as possible
as pungent as possible and leave most of
the details to the learning exercises
and to the supplementary notes at any
rate when our lecture today is called is
double sums or perhaps a better word
would be multiple sums but we will
concentrate on the case of double sums
for the usual reason that namely in the
case of two independent variables we
have convenient pictures still left at
our convenience now the idea is let's
consider a region are say direct the
square the unit square on the coordinate
axes with vertices 0 0 1 0 1 1 and 0 1
now what
going to do now is imagine that our is a
thin plate and what we would like to do
is define the mass of this plate are
assuming that the plate has a variable
density in other words what we want to
do is find the mass of the plate R if
its density Rho at the point x comma y
NR is given by Rho of X y equals x
squared plus y squared you see by the
way the reason I picked this particular
density distribution is you may notice
that x squared plus y squared
quite simply is the square of the
distance from the of the point X comma Y
from the origin and this will make it
very easy later for me to find will
lowest densities occur where greatest
densities occur whereas this may not
seem like a very applied problem notice
that if you want a geometric picture of
what's going on here the idea is is that
the density is varying radially as we
move away from the origin in other words
the density is the square of the
distance of the point from the origin
which means that the density is constant
on any circle centered at the origin
again the key building block that we're
going to use is again analogous to what
we used in calculus of a single variable
for example in calculus of a single
variable when we said that distance was
equal to rate times time
it was assumed that the rate was
constant in a similar way notice that if
we assumed that the density were
constant if the density were constant
then the mass would just be the density
times the area again most of us are used
to thinking of density in terms of three
dimensions that the mass is the density
times the volume I prefer to pick a thin
plate here simply to utilize a simple
diagram that I did not want to get
involved with three dimensional diagrams
another drawback perhaps to this system
is that you may be wondering why we're
not using the counter part of what area
was in calculus of a single variable why
aren't we talking about calc the volume
in two dimensions why couldn't we
somehow visualize the volume problem
here
again if that's what you'd like to do
notice that we could graph the density
as a function of the point X comma Y in
the region our plot the density in the
direction of the positive z axis in
which case the problem that we would
then be trying to solve would be to find
the volume of a solid that you get by
taking the parallelepiped whose base is
the region R and intersect that with the
surface z equals x squared plus y
squared again we will leave these
details for the exercises but the
surface Z equals x squared plus y
squared as you look in along the z axis
here is a parabolic Bowl opening up in
other words Z equals x squared plus y
squared if you take Z equals a positive
constant in other words slice this
parallel to the xy-plane if Z is a
positive constant x squared plus y
squared equals a positive constant is a
circle at any rate just to summarize
that the geometric equivalent to our
problem is find the volume of the solid
s if s is the parallelepiped with the
base R where R is just as given and the
top meaning it's intersected with the
surface Z equals x squared plus y
squared and again let me mention as an
aside that the same analogy occurs in
calculus of a single variable namely if
I write down the definite integral from
0 to 1 x squared DX I may view this well
in many ways but two of the major ways
in which I may view this the major one
that we emphasized in our course was as
an area I can also view this as a mass
more specifically let me take the region
R as shown here then you see one
interpretation of the integral from 0 to
1 x squared DX is that it's the area of
the region R another interpretation is
imagine that you have a very thin rod
geometrically of uniform shape in other
words is essentially a segment of the x
axis from 0 to 1 and suppose that the
density of this rod is a function of
position x say Rho of X is x squared
then notice in a manner analogous to
what we were just talking about the
ass of this rod would be found by
integrating x squared from 0 to 1 by the
way notice again a very important thing
that comes up here and that is that
these two diagrams may be used for the
same problem you see in many cases when
one has a density distribution like this
one visualizes the density being plotted
into in other words the density Rho of x
equals x squared is plotted as the curve
y equals Rho of X in this case y equals
x squared and we then think of a way of
being able to visualize what the density
is doing here in terms of the shape of
the curve here that's exactly what we
were doing earlier in the lecture when
we said that we could visualize the
density Rho of X Y as a function Z
equals Rho of X Y the analogy being that
with two independent variables we
wouldn't have a curve but rather we
would have a surface by the way again
notice how this emphasizes the fact that
the definite integral is in reality that
an infinite sum that it is convenient in
many cases to view this limit of a sum
in terms of an area under a curve but
that the definite integral itself exists
for more problems than just for
computing areas now at any rate are we
trying to point out here is that the
same analogy will exist when we go to
functions of several variables if in
fact we now return to the problem stated
at the beginning of the lecture we take
our region R remember what this is now
it has its the square with vertices at
these points we know that the density is
given at any point x comma y by x
squared plus y squared and what we'd
like to do now is find the mass of this
particular plate now just as in calculus
of a single variable the argument that
we use now is nothing more than if we
took a small enough region here we can
assume that the variable density was
essentially constant in other words this
is how one makes physical approximations
we break this thing up into small pieces
somehow or other find the mass of each
small piece and add those all up the key
point being if the pieces are small
enough
for an approximation we can say that the
density is essentially constant by the
way in the same way that we had to learn
the Sigma notation back in part one of
our course we will now have to somehow
rather learn to master the notation for
double sums the idea again being this if
I partition this into n equal parts and
this segment into M equal parts and if I
call a typical X segment Delta X sub I
and a typical Y segment Delta Y J then
to match up in coordinate fashion what
the mass of this little piece would be I
would call that the I J's mass
corresponding to the i-x partition and
the J Y partition and the idea is I'm
going to add all of these up that would
motivate the notation called the double
sum namely the way you read this is you
say let me first took a fixed value of J
and for that fixed value of J I will sum
up all these pieces as I goes from 1 to
n what that means pictorially is this I
will pick a fixed value of J well since
J controls the y-coordinate a fixed
value of J fixes your horizontal strip
and what you're saying is I will now add
up all the masses along that strip then
what you say is and then as I do that
let me perform that for each J as J goes
from 1 to N in other words what this
would say is add up all of the delta ms
along each row and then take the sum of
the all the possible values that the
rows can take on in other words I'll
take add up these pieces these pieces
these pieces these pieces then add those
sums together notice of course I could
have written this in the reverse order
namely this would say what first hold I
constant and for a fixed I some of these
as J goes from 1 to M in other words for
a fixed I sum these as J goes from 1 to
M and then sum over all the J's over all
the eyes at any rate the learning
exercises will take care of making sure
that you learn to manipulate this
particular notation the theory works as
follows what we do is assuming that the
density function is continuous at each
particular little rectangle that we have
here we pick the point which has the
smallest density we pick the point which
has the largest density we then imagine
that we had replaced this little segment
by the same area but with a material
which had this a constant smallest
density so that the true mass must be
greater than the mass of that piece and
then we assume that this little piece
was replaced by a new piece with the
same shape but whose density was
constantly equal to the greatest density
on this so this particular mass must be
less than the mass of the new piece and
in that way we ski we squeeze the truth
the true mass between two extremes again
just as we did in calculus of a single
variable and again to keep the notation
going the same way
I let Delta M sub IJ lower bar denote
the mass of the piece that I get by
replacing the density by the constant
density equal to the smallest density
Rho sub IJ lower bar treating that as a
constant multiplying that by the cross
sectional area Delta X I times Delta YJ
I prefer to call that Delta a sub IJ so
we don't prejudice either the order in
which we write these factors or the
particular coordinate system that one
wants to use but because I think you're
more familiar with Cartesian coordinates
I will continue to write this but the
idea is I compute the lowest the
smallest mass in other words an
underestimate in a similar way i compute
an overestimate
I then know that the true mast of my IJF
piece is caught between these two
therefore my total mass which is the
double sum of these over I and J must be
B cust B in turn cut between these two
double sums in other words what I have
now done is caught the true mass between
a lower bound and an upper bound and
again to write this thing more
symbolically so we can look at it here
what I'm saying is on the one hand my
mass must be at least as the great as
Britt as great as the value of this
double sum on the other hand it can be
no greater than the value of this double
sum somehow or other the same as I did
in calculus of a single variable I would
now like to put the squeeze on this as
the sizes of the pieces Delta X I and
Delta Y J are allowed to go get
arbitrarily close to zero in size what I
hope happens is that in that limit this
difference goes to zero so the M is
caught between two equal things and
hence the true value of M must be that
common value you see in a manner of
speaking theoretically nothing new is
happening that didn't already happen in
calculus of a single variable but from a
computational point of view limits of
single sums have now been replaced by
limits of double sums so that
computationally there is a degree of
difficulty more present in our present
study than there was in our study of
calculus of a single variable the
computation becomes more difficult
the theory stays the same now before we
start getting into the idea of what
limits mean let me just summarize this
for you
in terms of a more concrete
interpretation let me again take that
rekt that square R with its vertices you
know the same one we dealt with 0 0 1 0
1 1 0 1 and let me now take as a special
case the case in which I divide both the
X region and the Y region into two equal
parts so that my points of partition you
see look like this now you see the
advantage of picking my density to be x
squared plus y
where is that since the density is radio
what this means is that in each of my
partitioned rectangles in this case each
of my rectangles is a square you see
keep in mind that first of all I don't
have to divide these two dimensions into
the same number of equal parts secondly
they don't even have to be equal parts
but I've just for symmetry here elected
to do this just till we get an idea of
what's happening computationally and the
more difficult cases will be taken care
of in the exercises the idea now is what
that for each of these particular
squares the lowest density occurs at the
point which makes up the lower left-hand
corner because that will be the closest
point to the origin in each of these
squares and the furthest point from the
origin in each of these squares will be
the point in the upper right-hand corner
so you see in this particular case let
me do both of these at once to find the
smallest density in each of these
regions let me have the smallest one
written in the black chalk on the lower
part of this diagonal you see the point
0 0 corresponds to a density of 0 so the
lowest possible density is 0 in this
block the point 1/2 comma 0 is the
closest point to the origin in this
little square so x squared plus y
squared in that case is simply 1/2
squared plus 0 squared which is 1/4 the
closest point here is 1/2 comma 1/2 so
if we square the coordinates and add we
get 1/4 plus 1/4 which is 1/2 and in a
similar way the lowest density in this
block is also 1/4 now again using the
same argument the point in the first
block which is further from the origin
is 1/2 comma 1/2 that density
corresponds to 1/2 in other words 1/2
squared plus 1/2 squared so now putting
in the biggest densities in each block
and carrying out the computations in a
very trivial way we see that the maximum
densities are 1/2 here 5/4 here to here
and 5/4 here ok the idea is going to be
now that what we can now do is we know
that the area of each of these pieces is
1/2
by 1/2 which is 1/4 I will now assume
two different plates one will be the
plate which has the same shape as this
but in this quadrant here has a constant
density of 0 in this quadrant here has a
constant density of 1/4 in this quadrant
here constant density of 1/2 and in this
quadrant a constant density of 1/4 I can
now compute that mass and I know that
that mass must be less than the mass
that I'm looking for because I have
picked the lowest possible density in
each quadrant correspondingly if I now
compute the mass of another plate which
has the same shape but in which each
quadrant has the density of the greatest
value of the density in each quadrant
that must give me an over approximation
and so my mass is caught between these
two and just so to get an idea of what
this notation means notice that Delta H
sub IJ in this case is 1/4 for I equals
1 2 and J equals 1 and 2 in other words
our four elements of area are a sub 1 1
a sub 1 2 a sub 2 1 a sub 2 2 with if
you want to do these in order just let I
be 1 and 2 here J be 1 and 2 here for
example the dense the maximum density in
the first row second column well I'm
reading these the wrong way here the IJ
first row second column up this way is
5/4 the minimum density in that same
color in that same quadrant is 1/4 etc
at any rate what I'm saying is if I now
take the fact that for constant density
the mass is the density times the area a
lower approximation to my mass is
obtained by adding up all of my constant
densities and multiplying by the area in
other words 0 times 1/4 plus 1/4 times
1/4 plus 1/2 times 1/4 plus 1/4 times
1/4 that sum comes out to be 1/4
correspondingly the upper sum is what I
get by taking each of the constant
densities and multiplying it by the
constant area 1/4 that leads to a sum of
5/4 and therefore no matter what else I
know
about the mass of my region are I know
that it must be more than a quarter but
less than five quarters and the idea is
that by putting on the squeeze by making
more and more subdivisions I can
hopefully find the exact value of M sub
R but finding this exact value involves
a very very difficult computation namely
I divide this up into M times n little
elements of area I pick a point in each
region the density the density at a
particular point that I've picked out in
that region which I'll call CI J comma
di J is CI g j squared plus d IJ squared
this would give me the mass of a
particular piece and I add these up as I
goes from 1 to n as J goes from 1 to N
and take the limit as the maximum Delta
X sub I and the maximum Delta Y sub J
approach zero and this in most cases is
very very difficult and in fact even in
this relatively simple case what do I
mean by relatively simple case in terms
of a region what could be more
straightforward than our little square R
that we chose in general we'll have more
complicated regions let me summarize
today's lesson essentially by showing
you in particular what it is that we're
talking about in terms of double sums
namely what we're going to do is we'll
assume that R is a reasonable subset of
two-dimensional space and by reasonable
I mean that it's not a kinky type of
thing that leads to pathological
problems the technical words are things
like R is simply connected and things
like this we'll talk about that in more
detail what I'm saying is let me imagine
that R is a fairly well-defined region
in the xy-plane let me assume that I
have a mapping F that carries our into E
what does that mean f is a function a
real valued function of two independent
variables namely R is a two dimensional
space so a typical element in R is a
point is a two couple XCOM
why and we're saying here's an F Maps X
comma Y into some number remember ee1 if
you want to call it that is the set of
real numbers so the idea is let's what
we can say now is this let's take this
region R let's partition it into a mesh
not mess mesh of little rectangles here
let's in the ij3 angle namely the
rectangle whose dimensions are Delta X I
by Delta Y J let's pick a particular
point C and to identify it we'll call it
C sub IJ comma D sub IJ let's compute F
at that point all right then we'll
compute F times this area and we'll sum
this thing up as I goes from 1 to N and
J goes from 1 to n M and we're going to
take a limit as this partition gets as
fine as we wish meaning the size of the
pieces get arbitrarily close to 0 and
area both in the X and in the Y
direction notice by the way that because
this is not a rectangular region pieces
of rectangles are left out and that from
a computational point of view as you
make this refinement greater and greater
this is why the theory is so voluminous
on this particular type of topic you
must show that you're squeezing out all
the error and things like this but
conceptually all that we're really doing
here is the following what we do is is
we pick a particular point in a
particular one of these rectangles we
evaluate F at that particular point
which exists because we're assuming that
F is defined on this and if you having
trouble visualizing this F has nothing
to do with this boundary F is a function
which Maps each point into a number so
graphically you can think of f as being
a surface here namely if we map if we
visualize f of X comma Y as being mapped
with respect to the z axis we have a
surface coming out here and in the sense
what we're really trying to do is to
find an approximation for the volume of
the region cut off by this cylinder and
whose top is the particular surface Z
equals f of X Y but
getting about that for the time being
mechanically all we do is we form this
particular double Sun we form this
double salmon now I've put the brackets
in here to emphasize that what this says
is you first pick a fixed value of j and
sum this over all i from 1 to n and when
you're all through with that the I no
longer appears you have a sum that
depends only on J and you now do what
sum this result up over all values of J
as J goes from 1 to M and you then
compute the limit as the maximum Delta X
I and maximum Delta Y J both approach 0
now first of all this limit may not
exist secondly the limit may exist but
it depends on the order in which adding
these terms if after all we saw that we
could change the sum of a simple
infinite series by changing the order of
the terms certainly it shouldn't be
surprising that an infinite double
double sum isn't affected or is affect
it shouldn't be surprising that it is
affected if we change the order of the
terms so we have one of two ways of
doing this in terms of being
systematized do we first sum in terms of
the X's and then add up the the Y
increments are the other way around the
key result is this though it's that this
particular limit will exist and it will
be independent of what order you add
these things in provided only that the
function f is at least piecewise
continuous it can in other words that F
is a continuous function and if it's not
continuous it has breaks with only a
finite number of places and the idea is
that not only will this limit exist but
in a manner analogous to the definite
integral when this limit exists we
denote it by what we replace this by x
and y this gets replaced by DX and dy
and the double sum gets replaced by a
double integral and what we now do is
indicate what the region R is over here
in other words in terms of a summary
whenever I write down this expression
it's an abbreviation for a limit of a
double sum and what limit of a double
sum is it it's the particular
limit of this double sum if it exists
and that limit will exist if f is
piecewise continuous now the key point
that I want to bring out here and in
fact this will lead into the lecture of
next time also is that if I had never
heard of partial derivatives it makes
sense to talk about this kind of a sum
in other words
note that forming this limit does not
require any knowledge of partial
derivatives in the same way that finding
infinite sums in calculus one could be
done independently of any knowledge of
the derivative this particular concept
this particular limit makes sense even
if we've never heard of partial
derivatives and what what does this
double sum represent just by way of a
quick summary again there are two very
specific physical interpretations we can
give this one is that this double sum
represents the density of the plate
proof shape is the region R the mass of
the plate whose shape is the region R
and whose density at the point X comma Y
in R is given by f of X Y in other words
this part here controls the density and
this part here controls the shape of the
region a second interpretation is that
this limit when it exists represents the
volume of the right cylinder that means
a cylinder is obtained by tracing over
the region R with a line perpendicular
to the xy-plane that particular cylinder
whose top is the surface Z equals f of X
Y now those here are then the two
interpretations that we give this one is
it can be a mass the other is it can be
a volume the key point is that to
evaluate these double sums these limits
of double sums so if you want to call
them infinite double sums there is no
necessity for knowing partial
derivatives however one might expect
that in the same way that there was a
connection between single infinite sums
and ordinary anti-derivatives there
should be a connection between double or
multiple sums
and anti derivatives of partial what
well the antiderivative involving
partial derivatives it turns out that
this is indeed the case
we will talk about this in more detail
next time but between now and next time
what I would like you to do is to drill
particularly hard on these exercises and
make sure that you become familiar and
feel at home with the notation that's
used in denoting double and other
multiple sums at any rate then until
next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate